that's i never do that you see i hardly
ever skipped school
and every time i did god damn it you
caught me
i did it like three times one time i
drove to heinz
really it wasn't very i tell you it
wasn't very often one time i drove tines
creek to get away from you i thought
i'll drive to hinds creek he's not gonna
find me there and then on the way back
from heinz creek you drove by and waved
at me said oh my god he caught me again
so ridiculous
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody
i decided today that i'm going to
talk to my dad as the subject for my
youtube video and podcast and
find out
more about
his life his
young life on the prairie in
saskatchewan
about his father
my grandfather his grandfather my
great-grandfather
his mother
what it was like growing up back in the
40s mostly he's born in 1937 july of
1937
and
we've talked about such things but not
that much
and so there's lots of things i want to
know and so that's what we're going to
try to talk about today and i'm going to
walk through his life with him and
ask him a bunch of questions so that i
have the answers to the questions and i
hope you enjoy it
hello
hey jord
how are you doing
just as good as it gets good
glad to hear it so i thought i'd start
by telling the story of this third floor
that i built on my house
and so
one of the things we did
we were going to build a log cabin on
the
third floor of this semi-detached house
right in downtown toronto tammy and i
thought about that i guess we wanted a
cabin out in the woods but we thought we
could at least build one on our third
floor and and that sort of morphed into
this
native american big house which is all
made of wood inside
uh unlike the uh
the plaster
sheeting that makes up the rest of the
house so walking up there is quite a
transition and
we built it with some local architects
and with uh some input from
a quack coyote to carver who filled it
up with totem poles but on the walls
you and i talked about the possibility
of tearing some old wood off the
farmstead in saskatchewan off the
original buildings there that great
grandpa barent
homesteaded and so that happened when
the totem poles came across the country
on a 53-foot
truck
joel my brother had
helped tear a bunch of the wood off the
house
off the building surrounding the
original house
and off the barn and so
the wall
both walls
are done in gray wood or redwood because
some of the buildings were red that barn
red
or they're they're made of doors from
the buildings
so
and you had stripped some of that wood
off years ago
to use in your
room downstairs as well that was before
that anything like that was popular
yeah
yeah i took the
floor out of the
loft of the barn
and i used it for flooring in the cabins
at the lake
i didn't know you used it for flooring
there you also used it in a decorative
way in the pool room
that's pool table by the way not pool
uh
downstairs here you meet yeah
no that wasn't from the barn that was
from a friend of mine
oh okay okay well i think i got the idea
for using the old wood anyways we did
get the stuff stripped away from the old
farmstead so now your great gr my great
grandfather your grandfather baron
from whom my middle name is derived
he came to north america from
norway
no he was born in north dakota
or in minnesota
was it his father that came
yeah his father
and his father-in-law
did you tell me they built a boat and
came to norway or came from norway to
new york
that actually was
his his
father-in-law that built the boat
and
the two families came i think there were
i think there were a total of nine or
ten on the boat
yeah
they
left norway and
sailed all the way to new york
and then they ended up in the midwest
where there were a lot of norwegian
settlers
well yeah minnesota and north dakota
were the
uh
12 wisconsin too to a certain extent
they were just
the areas where the norwegians and the
swedes settled yeah
so they migrated that way
and then there was a move up into
saskatchewan
yeah about 1910 i think was the first
time that they came up
um
and homesteaded
and then they left again
because it didn't work out as i guess
homestead life was pretty tough
you know so they left again
but they didn't sell the place
they did have an auction
uh
my grandfather's old clock was in the
auction
and uh when they came back to
saskatchewan they went to an auction
they only bought it back
and i still haven't
so how did they get up to saskatchewan
from minnesota at that time
was it rail
no they drove up
in fact i think you have a picture
i think you have a picture of the old
car
that they drove up in i don't know what
it was
i can remember seeing pictures of it
they left and i presume they went back
down to minnesota but then they came
back
or where'd they go
north dakota place called vang
v-a-n-g
both families
were in that area
not not separated by too much
i think my grandfather worked in the
dairy there
and by both families who do you mean
well i mean my grandmother's family and
my grandfather's family and they and
they were married when they came up to
saskatchewan already yeah yeah
and so why did they decide to come to
saskatchewan if they were already
settled in in north dakota
well the grass is always greener around
the other side of the fence
yeah except when it is
in saskatchewan burr free free land and
[Music]
it's not colder in saskatchewan than it
is in north dakota
right and so the canadian government was
offering homesteaders at that time a
chunk of land if they would come in and
do what to it
well they had to prove it up
over a period of three years
i've forgotten honda i think they had to
break about 10 acres
the first year
and i think they were required to
have some sort of domicile
on it
and that's probably a loose word for
home
right
right and so
so
do you have any idea why they left the
first time
you said it was hard i mean we can talk
about that in a minute but
specifically we don't have
no i don't really have i imagine there
were a number of
factors
i'm sure life was fairly tough in
saskatchewan
i imagine they were homesick
anyway that's the story they left and do
you know how long it was before they
came back
i think it was about a matter of about a
year and a half something like that or
maybe maybe just a year
but i'm not sure of that george they
thought they'd give it another try and
the second time they stayed
yeah yeah
well maybe it wasn't as bad as they
thought you know
so what would it have meant to break 10
acres of land
at that time what would have you had to
do and how
well you took your axe and you cut down
the poplar that was on the place and i
guess there were a few spruce on it as
well
uh and then you took your grub hole out
and tried to dig the roots out
and you used your team to pull the roots
out and
pile them up and burn them and
cultivated the land as best you could
and probably sold some wheat on it
so that whole area so that was that was
near nakam saskatchewan if anyone wants
to look on a map that whole area the
prairie there would have been covered
with trees
yeah there were trees there
at that time
uh yeah it was covered with trees
so so to clear 10 acres meant you had to
cut down hundreds of trees i presume and
then you had to pull the roots out of
the ground one at a time with a team of
horses that's why you could only clear
10 acres or why you had to clear 10
acres you said in the first year because
10 acres isn't that big by farm
standards
i think it was 10 acres a year for three
years
to claim it up i don't know
i
these are things we never really talked
about when i was a kid
how do you know about it at all
well i guess
sitting around the table listening to
the adults talk
i picked up a lot of it
so how many kids did your grandparents
have
they just had the one
stanley stanley my dad
and stanley was adopted
he was
and was he adopted in the united states
or was he adopted in saskatchewan
he was adopted in saskatchewan
do you know if they knew
the did they know anything about him
did they know anything about his family
that i have no idea about
that was something that was never talked
about as far as i can remember
do you know how old he is
he was an infant he was an infant
um
i don't think i knew dad was adopted
until i was a teenager and then i
probably didn't believe it the first
time i was told
was it was it a shark
i don't know whether you'd call it a
shark or not it was i
i suppose it was a bit of a shock yeah
so and they had no other children
they had no other children
and so i remember
going out to that farmstead and that
would have been 25 years probably after
you
had left it
with great grandpa behrendt
you
a couple of times
to ride on a potato harvester he had
built and all the outbuildings were
still out there including the blacksmith
shop and the the i don't remember what
you called it it was this contraption
like an enclosed sled
that you used to go to school in
it was still intact caboose yeah you
called it a caboose why was it called a
caboose
oh god only knows
i don't know
i have no idea why it was called a
caboose that's probably a good question
to ask
google
all right so all right so you
barron and his wife
and i don't remember baron's wife's name
of course i never clara
clara
clara so they
built a log house
on the prairie
and a barn
and there must have been eight or nine
other buildings small shed like
buildings one of them was a blacksmith
shop
oh yeah well there were
you know there was a there were there
were different buildings over different
periods of time
um
but you're right there was probably
at least a half dozen other buildings
and the house and the barn and the shop
and the pump
which which was surrounded by a
big tire a big tractor big metal tractor
wheel
yes it was a real office steamer
that we made a trough out of
and the
cabin you grew up in which was the log
cabin
it was insulated with cardboard if i
remember correctly but when when i knew
the house it was still standing right we
could still go in it was still standing
well i think it's still kind of standing
maybe not i don't know i haven't been
there for a couple of years now
yeah the last time i saw it was a few
years ago and it had collapsed a fair
bit i don't think you could get inside
it anymore but it had a central room and
a bedroom on
did it face
which direction did it face they had two
bedrooms on the east side
okay so it was one room one main room
with two bedrooms on the east side
or was there a bedroom on the other side
too
no there was a kitchen
and
a hallway and a living room is went to
what we called it
and then there were the two bedrooms on
the east side
the house i guess was long
you know it was long north and south
right and was it wasn't very big
no how many square feet do you think it
was
like 600
yeah probably about that yeah like one
floor of my semi-detached
intro
yeah yeah and you had
two sisters
grow up with you there how many people
lived in that house when you were a
little kid
well how old was i
well how old are you
how old were you when you left that
house and moved into town
i was probably about
nine or ten
okay so you you you have you should have
some pretty decent memories of that
place if you were that old okay so how
many people lived there
in that house
from the time you were born till the
time you were 10.
generally speaking
well i guess there'd have been four
adults and three kids
four adults so your your grandfather and
your grandmother brent baron and clara
and stanley your dad
and bernie mother bernice bernice his
wife and your sister judy and your
sister betty both of whom were younger
than you
right okay how did all seven of you live
in that house there was two bedrooms how
was that how did you manage that
how did we manage that
i really have no idea how we managed
well
who who slept in which who slept in
which bedrooms
were all the kids in one bedroom
no that would only leave one room for
the adults
yeah
i don't know whether i can answer that
question or not i don't think i know
okay
okay you have us you have a soft spot in
your heart for that house
a soft spot yeah well you always go back
and visit it you know and you're
nostalgic well you go to the farm
yeah i guess i have a soft spot for i
grew up there yeah well what was it like
to grow up there
good
good how what did you do like when you
were a little kid when you were just the
earliest memories you have what are the
earliest memories you have of being out
there now you only sports you spoke
norwegian out there right primarily
well yeah kind of a minnesota norwegian
i guess
my grandfather and grandmother spoke
norwegian
[Music]
mainly
they could both speak english but
mainly they spoke norwegian
my dad
spoke norwegian when he was with my
grandfather and grandmother
and english the rest of the time
um
my mother bernice
probably could speak some norwegian
but we spoke some english too because
neighbors weren't always
fluent in norwegian
although a lot of them were
so what was life like there on the
farmstead when you were a kid you had
animals you had horses
we had horses and cattle
pigs
chickens who took care of them
well i think i guess they all did or
i shouldn't say we all did but my
grandfather and grandmother and mom and
dad
took care of them
and what did that entail
and how how many like how many cows were
there do you have any idea
well i would guess that there were
probably about six cows that were milk
producers and then
the rest were raised for
beef
excuse me
um horses
we probably had four or five horses all
the time
and did you ride a lot
ride horse yeah no
not very much
um
i rode some
but
i wouldn't say i was
a cowboy or anything
any in any particular reason were they
i mean did you like horses was it
interesting to you or were they work
animals
well both they were interesting they
were work animals i mean that's what
pulled the
pulled the implements when i was a kid
i can remember when we got our first
tractor
and i can remember when we got our first
rubber tired tractor
but i can also remember riding on
implements with my grandfather driving
four horses in front of us
plowing that and plowing and that sort
of thing and harvesting well i don't i
don't remember plowing as such but i
remember seeding
because on the cedar you could stand on
a on a platform at the back of the unit
and uh you had a good view of everything
and there was something to hang on to so
you didn't fall off
and we had an old dog named poots
who used to sit right up on the seed box
and
kind of look around the whole country
while we were doing that he got pretty
good at the bellings balancing
how big a farm would have the family
handled at that time
i think it was i think it was three
quarters as long as i can remember and
how many acres are in a quarter
180
160
160. so it was 480 acres and so the the
farm obviously expanded past the
initial homestead
relatively rapidly
that i don't know
i know who
i know who owned the quarters
that were bought and brought into the
farm but i don't know the details of it
and i don't
i don't know when right so when when
when baron and clara came back up they
made enough of a go at it the second
time to establish a farmstead that was
successful enough to buy
other
reasonably sizable pieces of land i mean
three quarters is not a immense farm by
modern standards obviously but it's not
no land at all it's
no it was it was probably at its time
fairly average
i mean there were there were families
that
had one quarter of land
uh
so
three-quarters was actually pretty good
and so everything you ate i presume
pretty much came directly off the farm
with the animals that you had so
eggs and milk you were were you milking
cows every day
well i wasn't
my mother was a great milker
i can remember her doing the milking
a good portion of the time
grandma showed me one day a picture of
the cabin
with the firewood she had split for the
winter
and if that cabin was 600 square feet
and a story high the pile of wood that
she split looked to be 1200 square feet
and about at least as tall as the cabin
when she said she split it
uh
i don't think she meant that she
manually split it
she may have had something to do with it
but we had a wood splitter
which was run by a small
gas engine
and
you could split wood to beat the devil
with it yeah well that sounds like a lot
easier than having to do it with an axe
i know that grandma was a busy woman um
but that doesn't she was
yeah well she must have had her hands
filled with three with three kids and a
whole farm to run and then when the
threshing crews came in if in the fall
if i also recall she used to have to
feed them as well
and that was a wood stove she and my
grandma yeah
and that would be
14 15 men
it pretty well filled the kitchen as i
remember it yeah i bet
so and they they were fed how many times
a day would she feed them three times a
day when they were threshing
three times a day
right so that's 52 meals for very hungry
men
and that would be one of her many chores
yeah
nobody said it was easy
no no when grandpa showed me one time
the or i saw a picture of him i think he
showed me though
the parka that he wore out in the winter
to do his farm work and
i mean saskatchewan is plenty cold it
gets to be minus 40 there on
no shortage of occasions and it also has
quite the blistering wind and
i mean it was a wool jacket and and
jeans essentially underneath it it
wasn't anything particularly bulky or
fancy
so
i imagine winter was pretty
well could be pretty brutal well i think
i think it was generally true that
there weren't
adequate
clothes for the for the temperatures
that we did have
i mean the the best you had was wool
you know
and
uh
wool was the main thing wool pants wool
underwear
a heavy wool coat if you were
lucky enough to have one maybe it had
canvas on the outside for windbreak
but those guys were tough you know
yeah well i remember grandpa's arms
forearms i mean
they were no joke when he was a he you
know i remember him from about the time
i was
10 i suppose think that's about where
his memories come from he would have
been 50 probably at that point
and i mean he had he had immense
forearms he was he's a very strongly
built person and
he had done plenty of work
so
did you have a happy childhood would you
say
did i have a happy childhood yeah well
like i said you're attached to the farm
i would say yes i had a happy childhood
okay and up up up to what age
well i suppose teen years
so what what made it a happy childhood
well what
what wouldn't have made it a happy
childhood well it means you have free
it's a breeze
you had acres and acres to
wander around in
there was lots of wildlife
there were some chores
it was just a good
life
what chores did you have to do
oh you had to bring in wood
occasionally you had to bring in a pail
of water
usually it was only about a half a pail
because you couldn't carry a whole tail
he had to go with the pump and pump the
water into the pail and then it wasn't
very far to carry it but
it had to be carried occasionally
so you weren't overwhelmed with you
weren't overwhelmed with chores by the
sounds of it
no i wouldn't say i wouldn't say i was
overwhelmed with it at all
no so you have something
i had some things to do
right right
and you did them
yeah
and if you didn't do them what happened
or did that just not happen
oh
i imagine it happened
i would imagine the scolding was
probably the
the main thing
who
from well the schooling would probably
have come from my mother or my
grandmother
daddy was pretty strict
he didn't scold much
so in what way was he strict
well
let's just say he was strict
well i i'm curious about your i i'm
curious about your relationship with
your great-grandfather and your father
because
you've
intimated that
in many ways you were raised by your
great-grandfather and i remember when i
was about i think grandpa
great-grandfather baron died when i was
about
nine ten not nine or ten yeah yeah on
that well that was the first brush i
really had with loss and i wasn't so
upset
with his loss because i didn't know him
that well i mean i was sad about it
because i liked him you know when
but you were really broken up by that
and so
that was the first time i think i ever
remember
seeing you
like emotionally distressed and it
lasted at least a week you know which
isn't a tremendous amount of time but it
was a tremendous amount of time as far
as i was concerned
yeah so it was
he was pretty important
yeah so
who
why was he so important to you
what was it about him and your
relationship with him
i think kids have uh
have a real
relationship with their grandparents if
they
are fortunate enough to have them around
and
you know i can remember
walking three steps behind him all over
the farm
so so you trailed around behind day in
and day out
uh-huh and and that was fine with him
yeah
or was it more it was fine with him was
it more than fine to go home yeah
okay well that's something
i mean
i remember the day for example we went
out and rode on this now he was quite a
handy person and quite a creative person
mechanically i mean this
this potato harvest here he built it
well you could drive it and i don't
really remember how it harvested
potatoes but he had built it pretty much
from the ground up if i remember
correctly
well it didn't really harm harvest
potatoes
it was built
so that you could drive it in a potato
patch without
driving over the roads
it had quite a bit of clearance and
outrigger wheels on it right right and
it put mainly it pulled implements that
harvested potatoes
i see i see so it was it was a
custom-built tractor in some sense it
was a custom-built tractor right
right and he did work in the
blacksmith's shop
oh he he was a good blacks he was a good
blacksmith yeah
and it was probably one of his
i guess you'd call it a vocation
because if it was raining or if it was
miserable
it was pretty easy to find grandpa and
me in the shop
because there was usually a fire on in
there and
uh
the building wasn't very large so it
was warm and there was always lots to do
what did you do especially for him
yeah what did you do in the blacksmith
shop where where oh hell i can't
remember now
i uh
there was always stuff to do in there
there was you know there was lots of
there was lots of junk pieces lying
around and
um
we had a we had a
um
i don't know what you'd call it it was a
wheel mounted on a on what was like a
stationary bicycle
and you used to be able to get onto it
and pedal so that the wheel went around
and then you could sharpen your sickle
or your axe or
your knife or
a stick or whatever you had and you
could spend a lot of time at that when
you were seven and eight years old
and what what sort of tools did he make
in the blacksmith shop
what sort of tools
well i can remember him building a grain
elevator
uh we'd call we'd call it like an auger
for grain
and i think
as i remembered he built almost all of
it out of
out of pieces
he bent
uh tin or the
galvanized metal that
built the chute and
wasn't awfully big it probably only
lifted the grain
maybe 12 feet something like that
but it worked sort of like it didn't
work like an auger it had a
it had a belt in it
so they had just picked up the grain and
moved it along on a
belt that had
i don't know what you'd call them even
paddles of what type
on them
yeah
he was always building something
so was it from him that you learned how
to use tools and to appreciate tools
because you like to build things i mean
you've gone smith well
i think yeah i think it probably was to
a large extent
due to him did he teach you i'm sure
did he teach you explicitly or did you
pick up most of it by watching
well both
i'm sure that he probably
uh made sure that i was
kept busy and out of trouble
while i was in the shop
and
you know that probably involves
straightening nails and
god knows what else
right so you had small productive jobs
to do while you were hanging about with
them well they they were i
you know
a job is what the body is obliged to do
mm-hmm
yeah yeah so this wasn't a job
if it's not obliged to do it then it's
fun or play
and so that's kind of how you remember
that as play
well i remember that's a good time yeah
right
so he was a he was easy to get along
with for you
he was good yeah
yeah very good to me
how about your
grandma grandma was great
yeah
how
what was great about well
well she was
extraordinarily kind
uh i can't ever remember her
disciplining me other than maybe shaking
her head or something
she taught me how to read at an early
age
uh we used to do
homework together
there were always treats
who knows
she was very kind
she taught you to read so that was how
you learn to read
yeah
i know i don't really remember learning
to read
i mean i always had people reading to me
my grandfather read to me a lot
so did mom so did my grandmother
i can remember reading the comics that
was very important
you know the cats and jammer kids and
little abner and that kind of thing
you know for a long time i didn't read
it they read it but after a while
well i don't know you kind of pick it up
so did people remember
go ahead did people in your house read a
lot when they were when they had some
leisure time
i wouldn't say a lot
because there wasn't all that much
leisure time
and uh you know for for many years
when it got dark it was dark
inside the house too
kerosene lamps didn't throw very much
light right did you was there ever
electricity in the cabin that you grew
up in
up till the time you left
no
so that was all kerosene
kerosene and later uh gas lamps
right which were a little brighter
yeah they were considerably brighter
right and so it never had it never had
power
right so people were up at dawn i
presume and then well in bed
well when it was dark and in the winter
that would be pretty early
yeah
so you had a lot of time to spend by
yourself if you wanted to wander around
out into the fields and
into the nearby
woods and
lake nearby
no
sloughs
uh
which
aren't as deep as lakes i guess
similar
but uh there were lots of sloughs around
and sloughs always had wildlife around
them
yeah i wandered around a lot when i was
a kid
i think i i think i knew every bush
within about five miles of home pretty
intimately
do you mean every tree
well not every tree but
i wasn't about to get lost in it
yeah well there's something about that
exploration you do when you're a kid
that really
familiarizes yourself
deeply with a place
i don't know if you ever do that again
in your life when you move you know like
i can remember
the houses around
the house i grew up in in fairview
far better in my imagination than i can
picture the houses in this neighborhood
like far better
even though i only lived there
for
eight years and i've lived here for
almost 20.
i still have a much better map house by
house in my head of the immediate
neighborhood i think when you're a kid
you pay attention to things in a
different way than you do
when you're an adult because
everything's so new
yeah
yeah
and
well
i believe you're right i think kids pay
attention
to what's going on
yeah i think we're at what hap
well you kind of your your perceptions
get kind of generic you know after
you've seen 300 houses
you sort of know what a house is and you
don't have to look at it anymore you
just sort of replace it in your
imagination with an image of a house you
know and that works as a placeholder but
you don't know
you don't know the back alley in detail
like you did when you were a kid
and you know i think you really lose a
sense of familiarity because of that
that deep sense of belonging to a place
is associated with that
really detailed exploration like i've
noticed in the houses i've moved into
and apartments
that unless i
any corner that i haven't cleaned
any drawer that i haven't organized is
kind of foreign territory in some sense
it's not
it's not friendly to me
but if i get in there into the details
and explore completely the house which
i'm trying to do with this house you
know we renovated it
two years ago three years ago but i was
so sick i couldn't
remap it and it seems really foreign to
me and i'm not happy in the house
because i don't really understand the
house you know it's alien to me and so
yesterday i spent
eight hours cleaning out a closet that
was full of stuff i hadn't been able to
touch for three years and that was a
great relief you know now i kind of like
my closet now i know exactly what's in
it i know exactly where everything is i
put it there like i sort of touched
everything it's mine now whereas before
it was just this place that was full of
stuff i didn't understand and a bunch of
work that i hadn't done and you know it
was leery of it there's still a lot of
the houses like that so i'm still not
comfortable here
but
but i will be i'm before i leave
in january we're going to go through
every square inch of it and
hopefully put it in order it makes you
much calmer to
know that where are you going into
january
i'm going on tour
oh oh oh okay going to washington first
for a week or ten days
right
i understand hey and i talked to joe
rogan the other day
yeah yeah so i'm booked on his show in
austin on the 24th
24th of
24th of january just just before the
tour starts it starts are you good on
the 25th yeah it was really good to talk
to him
i also enjoyed listening to those
yeah well rogan he's quite the guy
he's uh
he's done a lot of things he's tough
he's smart he's funny
uh he doesn't take any nonsense he's
nobody's fool
uh
and he's even handed with people and
generous and he's a good guy like he
really is a good guy he deserves his
success you know he's been a successful
martial arts fighter
he was a successful host on a couple of
tv shows he's been a successful stand-up
comedian and then he's been this
ridiculously successful youtube
interviewer and podcaster you don't get
successful at five different things
without being pretty competent
so so yeah i'm looking forward to seeing
him and he's a courageous sort too so
and he's fun to have a conversation with
because he has this great sense of humor
so so back to your to your grandfather
you spend more time with your
grandfather than with your dad
oh yeah way way more
and why was that dad
why was it yeah
why do you think it was
i mean was was that par for the course
in those days i mean sometimes kids
spend more time with their grandparents
if if they're well
i think
i think
i think grandfathers probably have more
patience
than
fathers do at times
i don't really remember spending
very much time with dad at all
did you get along with him
i guess i must have got along with them
when i was young
but as a teenager i would have to say no
i didn't get along with him very well
why
well i guess i was probably
i was probably his head strong as he was
who knows
what sort of things caused conflict
i guess damn near everything
now you were you were at the farmstead
until you were nine and then the family
moved into nakem and how big was nakam
at that time
oh it probably was
400 people maybe
and how much different was naked when i
got to know it when i was a kid from
from the nakem you grew up in
well i don't think it was
i don't think it was an awful lot
different
um i guess there probably were some
things you wouldn't do anymore
when you were
there
uh
that we did it
commonly every day
never thought anything about it
like what um
well
can you imagine uh uh how old were you
12
sure younger than that too but yeah 12.
okay 11 11 12 year old
walking downtown with the 22 in his hand
to the co-op store
to buy some ammunition
taking the gun into the store and
saying i need a box of shorts
22 shorts
and the people behind the counter
wouldn't even blink an eye they'd just
give you a box of shorts and take your
50 cents from you
i wouldn't try that one
when you were there even
you know no nobody was doing that then
no no
so that's part of that freedom that you
described
yeah freedom in common sense i think is
uh was a little bit more
common then
yeah well i wonder to some degree i
wanted to something i thought that tried
to think that through i mean
people
were working physically
and directly
in a way that they don't so much now
you know you're on that farm you're
contending with animals
while you're contending with the cold
you're contending with the heat you're
contending with the light for that
matter i mean
everything's
work but you're directly related to that
work right i mean there's an immediate
payoff you you go out and and the
chickens are there and you have eggs and
you go out milk the cows and you have
milk and you churn it and you have
butter and you turn the kerosene light
on and you have light and you light a
fire and you have heat you know what i
mean is that it's hard work in some
sense but the reward is instant plus
it's really real it grounds you
to the to the actualities of things and
then
you know people were younger when they
had their families and so i think they
were
more likely to grant their kids because
they were a little more wild let's say
being young more likely to grant their
kids a certain degree of independence
because they were still young and wanted
to have fun and then most people had
more siblings than they do now
yeah you know what and i think
one of the reasons that people are more
helicoptery around their kids now is
because they they wait till they're 35
to have them
and so they're older that by then and le
and more cautious
and then they only have one
or maybe two and so
they don't have ten you know it's like
you're not going to stay on top of ten
kids
that's not going to happen i don't think
you can stay on top of four and so that
means to some degrees the kids
raise themselves right in sibling groups
and the parents supervise but sort of
from a distance and
i think you probably get a lot
more realistic view of the world and
your place in it when you're
wrestling for position with like
six siblings
it's very hard to be hard to be
it's hard to be special in that
situation
i mean your siblings aren't going to
like that
so you never know what these shifts
cause and and that that that common
sense it seems to me that's associated
with like a grounding in real things and
and not this tendency we have now to
sort of
float off into abstractions
yep
yeah because when you're
even when you're trying to build
something and you're building it out of
wood let's say because i built lots of
things out of wood
it either works or it doesn't
you know it's really
the proof of the pudding so to speak is
right there in front of you
and you can't delude yourself into
thinking your table top is
flat
and straight when it's not it's either
flat and straight and the table is
stable and looks half decent or it isn't
so
yeah
yeah
i even thought saw you know in my
generation a lot of the young men
tinkered with cars because you could
yeah right you could understand a car
with a certain amount of work
and you could figure out how all the
parts worked and you could even repair
them they're like yourself sometimes you
had to buy a part but sometimes you
could repair them and you had to take
them apart and put them back together
and if you didn't put them back together
correctly they didn't work
and now cars are so sophisticated that
well they can't even get the hood open
no well they never break down virtually
i mean
well
they run a long time but you certainly
can't toy with them like you once did
they're they're not
immediately at hand in the same way
so
i like nakam you know i thought naked
was a fine town it was it was quite a
nice town it had a lot of brick
buildings when i was a kid in the
early 70s the downtown was still
thriving there was a butcher store that
was thriving there was a movie theater
there was a dairy that sold milk and if
i remember correctly at that time there
wasn't anybody who ran the dairy there
was just a refrigerator and if you
wanted milk you just got the milk and
you put your money in
basically what was a tin can
there were no locks on the door or
anything like that that's just how
people did it
and that was a certain community of
probably 2 000 people something like
that
maybe you're right maybe you're right
yeah
no then but by that time there was no
dairy in natum no that
that
milk came from milford which was 30
miles away right but that's still how it
was sold
oh that's that's exactly how it was sold
yeah the proprietor of the theater was
rel
smith and
he had a great trust in people i guess
and he said
he lost very little
money that he was aware of
yeah well he'd know if he made a profit
at least and certainly he didn't cost
him in staff
so
maybe and you never know maybe you know
any it's conceivable but probably not
the case that the odd pilfer might have
actually needed something to eat i
suspect no because
that isn't necessarily what drives
people to pilfering but yeah i thought
nathan was a real nice little town and
so and it it it was you know the streets
were nice and straight and the houses
were well built it was it was quite a
thriving little community it had a nice
brick school that's where you went to
school
so
um
so
who
everyone moved into nakem at the same
time your your grandfather no
no oh how okay how'd that work
well my grandfather and grandmother were
the ones who moved into
into fairview
and
naked
yeah nathan
they moved into nathan
and
i'm not sure why i ended up there
but it probably had something to do with
my grandfather and grandmother
anyway i was in about grade three i
think
when i
joined them in in nathan
and went to school there
and mom and dad and the girls stayed on
farm
you know it it sounds like we were
really separated but you know the
distance was about four and a half miles
and it wasn't as though you didn't see
them every day
because
most days you did see them
and was that was that an okay separation
for you were you
were you
unhappy about moving from the farm were
you happy to be moving into nathan with
your grandparents
yeah
i told you i got along with my
grandfather and my grandmother
exceptionally well
and what about your problems
mom i got along quite well with mom
she was very kind too
and what did she think about you moving
into town away from her
i really don't know jordan
uh
i don't know i know what you thought
about it well it was clear that she
loved you beyond belief i mean i
remember one time we were playing cards
up at the lake in saskatchewan and um
grandma was up there this isn't that
many years ago maybe 15 years ago
something like that
and so you would have been 70 i guess 68
something like that and grandma would
have been well in her late 80s and we
were playing cards and
oh you were getting teased i think
julian was teasing you and i think maybe
i was teasing you and
grandma said don't you pick on my wally
and she meant it and i thought oh this
isn't funny she wouldn't listen
she wouldn't have said wally
she just said walter yes that's right
that's what she said don't you pick on
my walter well really crack this up you
know because
well you know your 70 year old
grandfather by that point and she's in
her nearly 90 and it was just like
listening to
a 20 year old woman maybe talk about her
four-year-old child
mom definitely spoiled me
yeah well so she probably missed you
when you left
yeah she probably did but like i said
you
know it wasn't as though we were gone
for any length of time
uh at the very most it would have been a
school week you know
and probably
well
for a good part of the year it probably
wouldn't have been that because my
grandfather
always went to the farm every day
uh-huh uh-huh
you know honestly there was something
extraordinary going on
so do you did they move into town
because they finally had the financial
resources to have two houses
well again jordan i honestly don't know
i would suspect that that
might have been the case
yeah well those are pretty cramped those
are pretty cramped living quarters did
you get along with your did you get
along with your sisters
well i can i could say yes and i could
probably say no
on the whole i think we got along
relatively well
how much age difference was there
well
betty was two years younger than me
and judy was
seven years younger than me
yeah well seven years is a long gap
she was very spoiled
betty or judy
judy was very spoiled because she was
the youngest
you know betty was the in-between girl
right
right
so
when you were out in the farm did you
have a lot of friends or was it mostly
activity that centered around the farm
oh
had friends
but
you know they weren't they weren't right
next door right
you know they were they were miles away
but you had you know you had
you had the occasional friend that would
come over
and uh
i had a i had a a good school friend
called helmer of wonderbomb
and
helmer could really ride
and he used to ride over on his horse
every once in a while and
we would go for a ride
you know with with where around with him
me on my on me on the horse that i rode
not very well and helmer clinging to it
like a comanche
so how was it that he got to be a better
writer than you just more practice
more practice i guess yeah
and so well helmer helmer was probably
more of a cowboy than i was too
so what made you not a cowboy i mean
you'd like to carry your 22 rifle
downtown into nakem that sounds like a
pretty cowboy thing to do so what was
the difference
i don't know
i really don't know what the difference
was
difference in differences people
so
you could read before you went to school
yep
did you like to read
obviously
why are they stayed with it
what do you mean by that
well
i don't think you do things that you
don't like for very long do you
if you like it you do more of it
so you read
were you were you a reader in comparison
to your friends
or was that a rather common pastime
because my when i grew up
most of my friends didn't read
you know not much
so i was very
different well
yeah the difference though
was that i didn't know what my friends
were like at home very much you know
even when i went to to naked to school
i can't say that i really knew very much
about
very many of my friends as far as their
reading went
one maybe
anyway yes i could read before i went to
school i can tell you one
thing that i can remember quite well i
had learned how to
[Music]
do cursive writing
and this was before i went to school too
my grandmother had a
really lovely hand
and so did my grandfather uh you could
tell that they
were taught how to write
anyway
uh i was copying a comic
and i was doing it from
from the print to cursive writing
but what i didn't know was
that you stopped between each word
that sounds pretty damn simple but i can
remember that asking my grandmother
uh
how does this work now how do i how do i
how what do i do when i come to the end
of this word and start the next one just
connect them and keep going anyway just
an aside well it's simple when you learn
it but it's not necessarily obvious when
you haven't learned it
sounds great did you like school
yep did you like school all the way
through school
no no i'm sure there was periods of time
and
when i was a teenager that i would
sooner have been out farming or
out helping on the farm
in fact i think i've got one report card
that says something to the effect that
if
if walter attended
more regularly he would do much better
ah and that would have been junior high
yeah that was probably about grade nine
somewhere in there
so what did you do when you skipped
school that's i never do that you see i
hardly ever skipped school
and every time i did god damn it you
caught me
i did it like three times one time i
drove to heinz creek
really it wasn't very i tell you it
wasn't very often one time i drove tines
creek to get away from you i thought
i'll drive to hinds creek he's not to
find me there and then on the way back
from heinz creek you drove by and waved
at me said oh my god he caught me again
so ridiculous
oh well you weren't very you weren't
very inventive not not in that regard
that's for sure
no no
so why did you stay with school
you graduated was that com was that the
standard routine was did most people
graduate or did most people drop out
grade nine or grade ten
i again i don't really know
i would think that the majority
of kids of my generation
probably finished school
by going by that i mean go went to grade
12.
not all i mean i can remember several of
my friends dropping out
prior to
graduation you know in in the grades
before
but a good many of them finished school
yeah almost all my friends from junior
high
dropped out
you know while most of them went many of
them went worked on oil rigs and you
could understand that to some degree but
i had a completely different group jobs
jobs probably weren't that plentiful at
the time i got out of
uh got out of school or
was in school
anyway
great grandpa had a band
yeah yo i wouldn't say he had a band he
was in a bed
what was the ban do you remember the
name of the band
no hell no i don't know that that's way
before my time
well they they still played i can
remember seeing them play in the living
room
twice remember you can remember
some of them playing
i i think the majority of the ones that
he played with in the band were probably
long
[Music]
gone disappeared
was it was i don't know
was it a big band
oh hell i have no idea i don't even know
if you'd call it a band i call it a
bunch of guys that got together to play
for dances
yeah dad was a pretty good guitar player
and he could sing
yeah well i can remember grandpa singing
i mean we don't have
i don't think we have any recordings of
him singing which is too bad
but i can remember him singing he had a
pretty plaintive country voice and he
was pretty good guitar player
yeah he made me a guitar grandpa
yeah
i've still got it it's downstairs here
i know it's in two pieces what happened
was that in the closet
um it was strung too tight
and the neck
eventually worked loose from the body
oh i don't think i knew that
yeah that's what happened to it and i
guess you're not supposed to leave a
tightly strong guitar like that for too
long or perhaps i strung it too tightly
knowing very little about very little
about guitars
so anyway it's sitting behind the chair
down the basement
when did you meet mum
i would imagine that i probably met her
when i went to
integrate three in natum
what do you think of her
i think
that i thought she was wonderful right
off the bat
you think that
well yeah i kind of do
i thought that about tammy
yeah well yeah
i was right too haha yeah so was i well
good good for us
yeah
what the hell do you think accounts for
that
good luck
she told me she kind of knew too
okay
i don't know that beverly knew
[Music]
i mean we weren't we weren't always
uh
good friends even
mm-hmm
but
were you in the same grade or was she
one grade lower than you
he was one grade lower than me
right
tab and i were in the same grade so she
was a year older than me because i was
younger for the great but so we were
that facilitates a friendship being in
the same grade
oh yeah yeah definitely but but don't
forget
we were in
the same room oh right as the other
grade because right right
at least three grades in a room
so
we were probably in the same room much
of the time
when did you start going out
well
i think the first time we went out we
had been to a birthday party across the
road
from
where we lived in in nakam
and
some kind of a game
she had to walk me home which really
entailed walking across the road a
little bit farther
so if you count that one
we were probably
10 11 maybe
hmm
and obviously you count obviously you
count that one
yeah
when was the first time we went out
i think probably
it was
i think i must have been through school
grade 12
or past grade 12
and for some reason i knew that beverly
was babysitting
at her brother's place
that evening
and
so i went
and knocked on the door and
uh
said something witty like to them i'm
here or i don't know what
anyway i think that's the first time i
that we were together that way
and then
i think we were together most of the
time after that
what drew you together do you think why
was she attracted to you
do you know oh god only knows that
well you were you were pretty good
looking
oh yeah i was
really handsome rich
yeah no i don't i don't well maybe that
was it no i don't know
she probably made a big mistake
but anyway
well you you have your good qualities
yeah
fair enough what drew you to her
yeah
hey what drew you to her
what
what drew you to her
what drew me to her well i told you
i i always thought she was something
special
and uh
i probably followed her into saskatoon
when she
when she went
to take nursing
that was probably my main motivation
so you said that you
graduated high school and then you
basically followed mom to saskatoon were
you planning to go
on to further education
yeah i think i was
when did you decide you wanted to be a
teacher
oh
i don't know
i had a you know i had a couple of
really good teachers in high school
and maybe that was part of it i don't
know
joe faufenoff and
and uh frank dupont
what made them good
well they were just they were just
they knew their subjects well they
taught well
and
they we're good people you know they
were easy to get along with and
yeah did you i did a lot of i i did a
lot of marking for
frank
uh
on the weekends and that kind of thing
maybe that was part of it i don't know
these were men you respected
yep
yep still do
what made them good teachers
well i told you oh yes they they they
really knew their subject matter
they were interesting to listen to and
they were just good people mm-hmm
so you moved to the city
how how often had you been to saskatoon
before i mean that was that's a pretty
big city by nakam standards
how many times had i been there before
oh i would guess you could probably
count it on one hand
so what do you think of saskatoon
oh it's fine
were you excited to be in the city or
were you would you prefer what have you
preferred the small town and the farm
oh at that time i think i preferred the
city
i mean there was lots of you know there
was lots going on and that kind of thing
did you have a good time in university
did i have a good time yeah i think so
i had a car that wouldn't start when it
was cloudy but yeah most of the time it
was good
why would it start when it was cloudy
[Laughter]
don't ask me
was the most perverse beast i ever had
so
how old were you when you asked mom to
marry you
you mean the first time
how many times did you have to ask
oh hell i must have asked her
i have no idea how many times oh yes i
bet you know exactly how many how many
no i don't i don't know i i
tried to talk her into
marrying me
a number of times
and
she wanted to be a nurse and that was
that was the first thing to get done and
but yeah no i asked her i asked her more
than once i'm sure
i think i asked tammy five times
well
i i don't think you have the record but
i'm not sure she asked me once too so
that worked out okay the final analysis
oh well i don't know she actually yeah
she actually well she had come to
montreal to live with me and we had
discussed getting married but
she felt it was time and she actually
asked me on
isn't it sadie hawkins day isn't that
yeah yeah no we didn't even know it we
didn't even know it it just happened
that way we know it no yeah so that was
pretty funny little little abster a
little admirer was it just as real as
santa claus you know
yeah yeah so
and i said yes it's a good deal it was
it was a good deal yeah yeah that's a
good would you would you say that you've
had a happy marriage
yep i would say i have had a happy
marriage
what was more important to you your
family or your career
no doubt
at all
family
what was the best part of what was the
best years you spent with your family
well i i think the best years were
the years that you guys were home and
growing up
they were great years and of those years
younger kids older kids
what was better for you oh
i i can't say that because it was all
good
uh
no
there's no doubt that was the best time
of my life
why
oh who knows why come on i think it's
it's instinctive
for some people
yeah well you're really good with little
kids
well there was no doubt
you seem to trust them
well i seem to be relatively good at
that yeah
and most little kids trusted me
yeah
not not very many that i
had shy away from me so you spent a lot
of time with me when i was a little kid
yeah
what do you what do you remember about
that particularly
what can i say
what do i remember
i don't know
i remember
quite a few things but i don't know if
any of them are god awful important you
know well pick one there
well
i remember the time that we hatched
those chicks
in the porch in nipplewood
didn't have one yeah that was cool
that was that was interesting pretty
good yeah
uh
i remember
driving home with you to nakem
a number of times and
talking the whole time because you'd
never stop asking questions
yeah well
hasn't changed much
no i know
you kinda are who you are
yeah that's right
no there were lots of good times jordan
all good times
i think i remember mostly
when i was little kid
reading with you
oh yeah
yeah well that was great that was so
much fun
i thought so
because what i remember i was pretty
little but what i remember is that
well first of all we had a dr seuss book
come
every week or something like that
because we were in a book club
and used to come home every
every night
and after dinner we would
sit lay on the rug we had to hook one of
those hooked rugs
and we'd lay on the rug and you'd put
your arm around me and
away we'd go through one or two books
and
you taught me to read you know
and i remember
that going on for quite a long time
and it was wonderful to have the
attention
and uh well and to be given that gift of
literacy as well
and have it instilled in me in such a
young age
you know i mean i loved reading
it's really shaped my life in every
possible way
so
you know and i remember
you know
one of the things that was different
about you we had our differences when i
was a teenager it sounds kind of like
the ones you had with your dad you know
both stubborn and i you know i had
hanging around with rough kids
and we misbehaved a lot
a lot of drinking and that sort of thing
you know and i
you you put up with them
that's about all you should have done
really i suppose
but
most of my friends you know they didn't
have a good relationship with their
fathers they had no respect for them
that was i know
yeah
yeah it was really rough on them those
those my friends those are my teenage
friends or you know the ones in junior
high yeah
i know and uh
you know when we were
alone with my friends
they'd have a bad interaction with their
dad or something and they'd be pretty
hard on them met badmouth them and i
could tell they were mad bitter
resentful angry about it and they had
their reasons or hurt by it or a
combination of all those things
disappointed but i never felt that way i
mean even when we had altercations
i knew that fundamentally
despite whatever altercations we might
have
that you were
on the side of my better angels
let's say
well
yeah well that's a tricky thing to
manage you know
yeah but it's a tricky thing to manage
because when you have kids you kind of
on the one hand you want to like the kid
you know
but on the other hand you want to like
the kid that they could be even better
so you have to kind of balance that
acceptance for
an appreciation for who they are right
now with a desire to
foster further development
and i think mothers sort of specialize
in the former and dads to some degree
specialize in the latter
it's not that cut and dried obviously
but the fact that you had belief
in my potential
was
has always been
of
inestimable value
and one of the things that really hurt
me when i went on tour and talked to so
many people
was that
that was so lacking for so many people
you know they didn't have someone who
really had their back like really when
the chips were down both you and mom i
knew that
i knew that that was true and that gives
you kind of a foundation underneath you
you know or you obviously had it with
your
with your grandparents and your mother
yep
i don't know what it would be like to
grow up without that
you know
you'd be pretty lost pretty alone yeah
well it's
there's no doubt it would be tough
anyhow we
always
always said we were young and dumb so
everything goes well
yeah well what's been the most
challenging part of your marriage dad
what's been the most challenging part of
being married
because you've been married how long now
i don't know 60
i don't know 64 years something like
that yeah well that's a long time we got
married in 60. what does that make it
61.
61. yeah it just feels like 64. yeah it
just feels like 64. yeah
yeah
most challenging thing
jesus
i
don't know
i guess maybe the most challenging thing
is
trying to be a decent person because i
have a lot of trouble
with that
what do you mean
well
just
that
what do you have to control
well
i
i'm very stubborn
i guess probably quite opinionated
and very vocal
all those things
can cause problems and i know
that they've caused problems for your
mom
yeah well mom's kind of gentle person
although she's got a spine
yeah she's a good person yeah she is a
good person she's easy to get along with
she laughs a lot
friendly outgoing
yeah i can't i can't even remember
really having a fight with mom you know
and when the kids when we were kids and
we used to make her upset you know
because we were rambunctioning around
too much
um
and we made her upset that always made
us feel guilty because you know
mom didn't get upset
if you if you made mom upset you were
probably being bad
so we just feel guilty about it
so
yeah well you know
being stubborn and opinionated and
assertive has its virtues too
well they have its virtues but they are
making it very difficult for us
yeah well it's not easy to negotiate
continually with someone under the same
house and you and mom are quite
different in many ways too
so you have those temperamental divides
to get
to to cross i mean she's more
extroverted and social than you are
yeah i wouldn't say i was extroverted
and social
no well you took my personality test
right and i mean you were assertive on
the extroverted scale but
low in enthusiasm
whereas mom is high in enthusiasm
and not as assertive
so you remember things
too long yeah well i was curious you
know
yeah well it's probably true
yeah well i didn't you know i gotta say
when i when i grew up i never saw you
really back down
so that was something no
you uh
i don't back down very often
and i'll be damned if i'm going to back
down to this government
or whatever in the hell we've got
so when are we going to see each other
again do you think
well
i guess when you come to see me
because i can't go anywhere
and i can't see
i can't see it changing
yeah i'm not very happy about that
no i'm not neither
but i gotta live with me too
yeah i know
i'll come up
i got my two around pretty soon
yep i'll figure it out to come up
good
got anything else you want to say
what what what
what's the best relationships you've
ever had in your life
the best relationship yeah
i guess for me your mother
you
born
joel
yeah well you know in our culture
kids
they get a bad rap you know
but one thing
if you're careful
you can have the best relationships
you've ever had in your life with your
kids
that's really something
the thing is they pay you back for you
know people think of kids as this
like interruption in their life or an
inconvenience or
no
no
that's not right
they're the best thing that ever happens
to you if you're careful
you're
right
anyway
yeah
yeah before we can't talk
before we can't talk yeah
off to the uk tomorrow
yeah
well we wish you luck thank you
i don't think you need it but
uh
it's good to have some luck too
yeah it's going to be an incredibly
exciting trip ridiculously exciting trip
it's a ridiculously privileged trip i
will
i'll call you
i'll call